three kegs that error if we went to
Nigeria or anywhere in Africa Morocco
South Africa bro that era would never
ever be I don't want to say it's never
ever be replaced but like it's just
something that's it was a special moment
I feel proud to be part of that you know
what I mean so yeah it's bigger than
that even someone said to me when umaru
was about to fight Tyra Woodley to win
the Belt
doesn't win so you could be the first
African Champion I was like what yuck I
was like what kind of mentality do you
have to have yeah that you think like I
would want my boy to lose so I could be
the first I'm like no his wit is my win
when you come from scarcity the idea of
abundance is incredible right you're
like I want three African Champions
that's the most amazing when you come
from abundance the idea of scarcity is
really exciting so that person who asked
you it is